uh well King Charles A sensationally
evicted Harry and Megan from Frogmore
Cottage in Windsor and reportedly
offered it now to prince Andrew who has
to vacate his own larger home well the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex were given
the college as a wedding gift by the
queen in 2018 and will now be left
without a home in the UK after
Buckingham Palace served eviction papers
tonight A spokesman for the couple
confirmed the sun's bombshell scoop by
saying they have been requested to
vacate the property or Kevin McGraw
still I've been joined Now by talk to
vegan sugar domestic raccoon and as
Jordan and author uh Tessa Dublin well
so Kevin this is one of those excuse me
great Scoops
um this morning
um and completely true it turned out
there have indeed been kicked out and
been evicted yeah there's a new sheriff
in town he's going to be the Iron King
because he was the act of a king not a
father in other words has he basically
put his new status as the Monarch and
the interests of the monarchy and his
role as king above actually what maybe
he's instinct is as a dad well it could
be as a dad he believes in tough love
he's also said to be very emotionally
cold and probably you know not best
suited to try and bringing them back in
and all in a warm way but it is pretty
Sensational as you say because I thought
he would try and find Common Ground try
and build Bridges get some peace but
this is right if you're going to go to
war with me I'm going to fight back
right and it does beg the question
Esther uh coronation coming up in early
may only a few weeks away now
invitations apparently going out next
week 2 000 of them I mean I would put
good money now that there'll be no
invitation heading his way to Montecito
in California I think so too look I was
very skeptical when I saw this because I
thought the palace just asked them to
take the rest of their belongings and
ship it back to Montecito but the fact
that they've actually been given a
formal eviction notice yes it's very
clear you're not coming back there are
no warm sort of olive olive branches
being extended to you if that's a thing
uh and it's it's really quite scathing
actually can you imagine just being
evicted by your own father it is but
I've just written a column for the sun
about this and I you know you and I
we've argued about this but putting
aside our different opinions about them
as people there does come a Tipping
Point in any Feud of this nature where
if one side just continues to publicly
attack the other on the global stage
that Megan and Harry have not just with
Oprah Winfrey but then a six-part
Netflix documentary series then a 400
page book trashing everyone including
Kate and Camilla and so on there is a
Tipping Point for anybody however much
Charles may want to be a good dad
William I'm told was utterly
incandescent after that book and I think
this is the logic apparently this
decision was taken the next day after
the book came out is anyone surprised
really I'm I never think it's a good
idea to make a decision like that in
haste you then repent at leisure I think
given the coronation is as you've
mentioned but weeks away and that we
want our monarchy to look broad shoulder
to look Global to look like it's an
institution that understands what
Redemption means I think the timing's
unfortunate I think the Optics around
asking Uncle Andrew the disgraced Jew to
move in also is deeply unfortunate
although I would question yeah that that
whether this is on numerous levels the
right decision at the right time I
certainly think Kevin the Andrew bit to
me was Ill thought through because that
gives all the people who support Megan
and Harry and don't want to believe a
bad word about them I said really you're
going to put the guy that paid this
woman who says he never met millions of
dollars to avoid having his day in court
you're going to give him their Cottage
because somehow he's better all I would
say to counter that I was in America
last week and a new poll came out while
I was there saying that they are now
less popular in America than Andrew yeah
I mean that is how far
their standing has fallen it could be
because in America they've forgotten to
some extent Andrew although he is the
real scandal in the royal family I think
Harry and Megan haven't behaved by uh we
haven't behaved well others I don't
think it behaved well on the other side
but to give them that five bedroom house
is adding insult to injury for them I do
think it's a bad move I mean if he needs
a house let him get on a council waiting
list like everybody else why should he
be gifted a multi-million pound two or
injuries and Meghan markle's yoga room
what another thing is he doesn't this
old man doesn't need a five-bedroom
house I think he needs a one bedroom
flat and stevenage well apparently
Andrew doesn't even want Frogmore
College he wants to stay where he is
which is a much larger property he would
be seeing it as a demotion because
Andrew is pretty deluded about most
things let me ask you on the coronation
specifically it is coming up I mean
should he be invited never mind Willie
should Harry and Megan actually get an
invitation absolutely not that's what I
think why why do they all right go go to
the father bit look families fall out
one-on-one let me go to the father bit
for you because I put this in my color
if one of my three sons all in their 20s
now and I'm very a great relationship
with all of them if one of my three sons
spent years publicly trashing our family
all the members in it right and the Very
institution of our family they would not
get as I put in my column the remaining
ash from my Christmas Day cigar let
alone a grace and favor home you're
talking to in your column you're talking
to a little bit dare I say it of middle
England we want our monarchy to be
bigger and better than that is who's
weird the Great Britain no we want the
state no we want Renegade once our oil
cake and eat it Royals yeah who've been
treacherous to stay in California and
actually sink or swim by being Megan and
Harris you're not the Duke and Duchess
it looks like you're getting what you
want because actually this wasn't as
somebody said this morning Frogmore
Cottage just a place where they lay
their heads it actually came with the
umbrella of security that you get as
being part of oh please
protection they're so obsessed about
privacy and security
hang on you've got what you want let me
respond to you these two apparently are
by yours stick obsessed with privacy and
security right right they've just done a
six-part Netflix documentary into their
private lives at home one they don't
care about privacy they want to sell it
secondly on security Harry was
unbelievably reckless in the book to
boast about his Taliban kill numbers and
to describe the Taliban victims that he
killed as chess pieces he by doing that
immeasurably worsened the security for
his family immeasurably and as any
military expert will tell you so don't
let me hear them talk anymore about
privacy and safety when he has so
deliberately invaded his own privacy and
worsened theirs I'm merely pointing out
that whether he's exacerbated his own
situation or not they are always very
concerned we saw them last summer they
hardly left from the cottage Etc nor was
there any security incident around them
they have highly paid bodyguards did you
know what peers you've got what you want
and in the end it's the nail in your own
someone I want and yes yes been you've
been shouting them down sorry no no no
way this is quite clear I think they are
a malevolent Duo intent on fleecing
their Royal titles for hundreds of
millions of dollars and causing Untold
damage to their family and the
institution of the process I do believe
that but I haven't evicted them from
this home Harry's father as a victim
from the home Harry's brother wanted
them evicted from this home I'm damn
sure of it because they are sick and
tired of not just them being trashed but
their wives being Trashed by these two
Kevin makes it this is you've got your
finger on the Tabloid plus this if they
don't come to the coronation in terms of
attraction in terms of attention it this
is a depletion I'm sorry
nobody cares look there's grotesque
inequality out here in unfairness when
these houses are standing empty in a
country where the homelessness uh crisis
but if they're not there not the
coronation they won't be missed no in
truth the event will just it's the other
way around they are there they become a
massive distraction and by the way if I
were William and Charles and Kate and
Camilla I wouldn't trust the parents um
as far as I could throw them they could
remember Harry went to Prince Philip's
funeral and he then went and had a
private conversation with Charles and
William immediately afterwards at the
scene of the funeral and then he put all
of that in his book but this is a guy
who was ranted about the media about
tabloid editors like me for invading his
family's privacy and all this kind of
garbage and yet there he is invading his
family's privacy at the most
excruciatingly private time revealing
conversation Michael Andrew in a front
row at the coronation
you're presuming you're presuming we
want that as well exactly and and ask
you why would you even want them there
why would you want to see a pair that
have trashed their family for years why
do you want monarchy bashes there
because actually that's canceling Hall
event that's an easy way let's scrap it
save the money and I know it's hard you
know the pain
I think they've slightly lost you yeah
who've lost You've Lost Your Venom about
this you've lost your spark you've lost
the ability to rise up and defend them
because in your heart you know Tessa
I've been writing about them the whole
time do you know what you're doing by
you I've just seen you actually so
watching a helium balloon when it sucks
out you know because that is a slow like
but actually You've Lost That Thing That
crackle yeah no where you felt genuinely
felt they were right now you think you
know what they're just they've lost me
no what saddens me peers it's
no is that there you are they're
smacking your lips thinking that you've
won something but the bigger picture is
our monarchy by all of this has been
depleted and actually it's a monarchist
site on Saturday no actually what
Charles has done in my view very smartly
he's now moving to save the monarchy and
his reputation from these two flame
friends from these two flame throwers
who keep wanting to trash it and burn
into ground lovely to see you Jesse
lovely to see you Esther and Kevin